[Musique]
la Chine est en voie de compléter la
construction de sa station spatiale 3
taikonautes sont déjà à bord de la
station Tian Gong qui pourra à terme en
accueillir 6 à la fois et les ambitions
spatiales de Pékin ne s'arrêtent pas là
[Musique]
conquérir l'espace c'est le rêve des
Américains mais aussi celui des Chinois
par le niveau de ses activités c'est
déjà la seconde puissance spatiale de la
planète
3 janvier 2019 la Chine pose un robot
sur la face cachée de la Lune
29 avril 2021 le pays à mort sur la
construction de sa station spatiale
15 mai 2021 elle pose un Rover sur Mars
depuis 25 ans Philippe Coué analyse et
décortique les avancées du programme
spatial chinois pour les médias du monde
entier pour lui il ne fait aucun doute
les sciences spatiales chinoises sont un
ébullition
sachez probablement pourrait en fait
concurrencé directement les États-Unis
d'ici 10 à 20 ans cachée est une grande
puissance qui a des ambitions qui sont
moins régionales et plus planétaires et
oui elle a largement très largement les
moyens maintenant de ses ambitions et
ses ambitions sont vraiment très très
importantes
l'an passé seulement Pékin a effectué 55
tirs en orbite avec une cadence de
lancement aussi élevé ses visées
spatiales sont sérieuses
on est passé en fait en 10 ans de 15
tirs par an à plus de 50 aujourd'hui ce
qui est en fait une progression
phénoménale et qui démontre en fait
cette volonté de toujours progresser pas
seulement pour être le premier mais
vraiment parce que il y a beaucoup de
besoins en matière spatiale en Chine
la recherche spatiale chinoise comprend
plusieurs chantiers d'envergure dont la
construction d'une station spatiale la
SSC elle sera complétée en 2022 sa
construction aura duré moins de 2 ans de
l'extérieur ces modules ressemblent en
tout point ou sous US russe quand on
regarde dans le détail l'intérieur du
vaisseau sa strictement rien à voir la
propulsion est différente la bionique
est totalement différente et
l'architecture même du module orbital a
été modifiée et optimisé par rapport à
ce qu'on fait les Russes qui prennent ce
qui existe déjà mais il le réinnove on
l'appelle ça la rénovation à la chinoise
parce que sur un objet ils vont
l'optimiser
si sa voisine la Station spatiale
internationale accueille des astronautes
du monde entier pour des missions
scientifiques celle des Chinois semble
vouer à une mission plus large
aujourd'hui il y a peut-être plus une
volonté d'habiter l'espace pour
l'habiter et pour faire autre chose que
de la science qui a cette volonté en
fait d'utiliser l'espace pour l'économie
en fait
l'exploitation commerciale de l'espace
elle est encadrée par les accords
Artémis une quinzaine d'États d'agences
spatiale les ont ratifiés mais pas la
Chine cela ne veut pas dire que Pékin ne
s'y intéresse pas son projet de central
solaire orbital en est le meilleur
exemple
cette centrale prendrait la forme d'un
tapis bardé de capteurs solaires large
de plusieurs kilomètres carrés il serait
déroulé en orbite basse
la construction en fait dans l'espace
d'immense station orbitale qui sera en
fait en orbite gestionnaire et qui
ferait plusieurs kilomètres carrés voire
des dizaines de kilomètres carrés vous
voyez le projet est complètement
colossal il prévoit en fait une première
station expérimentale en 2030
c'est-à-dire dans 8 ans non seulement
pour fournir de l'énergie pour elle-même
mais aussi éventuellement la
commercialiser pour pour les autres mais
pour que ça devienne économiquement
viable en réalité il faut aller chercher
des matériaux d'abord sur la lune et
après au niveau des astéroïdes par
exemple
pour ces centrales notamment que la
Chine s'intéresse aux ressources
lunaires
ils ont annoncé il y a quelques semaines
l'objectif de se poser dans quatre
points différents de la lune pour
rechercher
la présence de matériaux qui poil les
interdisés pour faire en fait ce genre
de station donc et là c'est un aspect
important de la future conquête
l'énergie chinoise parce que ça ne vise
plus uniquement que la science il y a
bien une volonté en fait chez eux
de s'installer
[Applaudissements]
mais dans tout ce projet la Chine craint
un homme
mask le fondateur de Tesla et de Space X
avec son nouveau lanceur Starship la
conquête spatiale pourrait prendre une
nouvelle tournure
si en fait ce Starship arrivait à
décoller effectivement cette année on
pourrait considérer que dès 2022 et bien
on changerait complètement de paradigme
en matière de transformation spatiale et
je rappelle que ce véhicule c'est pas
seulement pour atteindre l'orbite
terrestre mais c'est franchement pour
explorer et éventuellement coloniser
toutes les terres du ciel
Starship c'est un lanceur aussi gros
qu'un Airbus A380 il est deux fois plus
puissant que Saturne 5 le lanceur
utilisé par le programme lunaire Apollo
la promesse de musk c'est que tout soit
utilisable et que le tir d'un Starship
ça soit au taux de 10 millions de
dollars avec une flotte d'au moins une
centaine de véhicules qui partirait tous
les 6 heures donc la promesse c'est de
transformer l'accès à l'espace
face aux promesses du store ship la
Chine est confrontée à un réel
compétiteur
l'Académie des Sciences c'est un peu
plus d'un an en fait a donné pour mandat
aux gens qui font des lanceurs et bien
d'être capable en 2040 de réaliser
chaque année le transport de 10000
personnes dans l'espace et de dimiton de
fret c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est dans les cartons et qui était
présenté très récemment avec d'abord des
lanceurs qui ressemblent en fait au
Starship ou dérivé mais la volonté à
long terme d'avoir du trafic entre la
Terre et l'espace qui ressemble plus au
transport aérien avec des véhicules qui
sont des véhicules ailés la station
spatiale la lune les lanceurs ce n'est
pas tout la Chine reboothie de mars elle
prévoit d'ailleurs y envoyer une mission
habitée en 2033 des Américains ou des
Chinois seront les premiers à y déposer
le pied
l'objectif chinois est clair devenir une
superpuissance sur terre comme dans
l'espace
[Musique]